in the Kickstarter video Christopher you
talked about how you'd like to make
currency different from other
environmental documentaries and that
sometimes they seem more sort of like
science like like it's more of a
academic you know video or something how
do you propose doing that with currency
how will it be a little bit different
without giving away too much about the
term so what drew me to currency is a
film in particular as a filmmaker is
that I thought it was a very exciting
story there's a lot of inherent conflict
you know over these resources and even
though the sort of setting and what's at
stake and all that is definitely
environmental in its nature and it has
to do with protecting environment at the
heart of it is really a human drama and
you know there's a lot of different
aspects to that drama too there's you
know poverty and people trying to get by
but there's also politics and government
and corruption and there's also you know
what broader seems like you know greed
and love and kindness and all these
things and so I mean I just thought that
was an amazing framework you know to
address a social issue and also this
came about not too long after cartel
land was around and it really struck me
as when I went to sell cartel land I
thought you know and I think there are
some you know fair criticism that movie
so I'm not I'm not trying to sell their
like the best thing ever but it really
is it's a great movie I enjoyed it
I enjoyed it a lot in fact that I felt
inspired to make sort of a similar film
with a similar vibe to it and I thought
that but I wanted to do an environmental
and I just thought this had all the
pieces for that and and so yeah I mean I
think that that's kind of what I mean
it's not by no means not the first
environmental film that's like a
thriller I think The Cove and racing
extinction which I was involved with
also have elements of that although I
think that those are lot
Caretti and then what oceans have been
what currency is going to going to be in
the end but and then there's also
another filmmaker beginning stammering I
know but he did Mara mato and he just
had another one that premiered at
Rebecca I called a river below and I
think that he does similar kinds of
things so um so I don't want to claim
like this was totally unique in its in
its tone or vibe however I do think that
we need to find a way to connect with
people on the environment that is more
than just your typical science lesson
about you know climate change and you
know I think you see a lot of
environmental filmmakers doing this
right now with you know Jeff Arlovski
which is in coral it's like he is
talking about coral bleaching but really
who's following you know these
scientists and photographers who are
trying to capture it visually so the
story there is really the like people in
so you really got to find that human
story at the center of the environmental
issue and I thought that just this one
was you know a very exciting one that's
going to hook people so well it sounds
like you have four stories in the sense
you have the the journalists and then
you have the environmental gentlemen and
then the two students so so do they all
sort of come together and that or or is
it more focus on one of the two men on
that yeah okay so basically they we met
them all through connections from each
other really so their stories intersect
and they weave together and in it really
I think all of their stories and on
stories and many other people there are
part of the same story
we do focus a little bit more on the
journalist Matt and then also on Paul
who is on the island and starting the
marine fisheries protect area and also
and the students we met on Paul's Island
so they're kind of part of that story
too
yeah I mean I just I do think that it's
we it's not really like four
intertwining stories as it is one story
where we have different characters that
come along in the journey and show up at
different times and
and stuff like that so how is that for
them to what did you did you speak to
all of them beforehand and letting them
know like look there may be parts of the
somewhere you won't necessarily like how
you're portrayed I mean that's always a
for any documentary that you're doing or
it doesn't seem like that's come up yet
because people are so they don't they
only want to be seen the way they see
themselves and sometimes the camera
shows a better angle a worse angle
neutral so you know it's a it's a fine
line how is that well that's one of the
things that's really important like in
addition to the initial email and the
initial access getting I guess creating
a good relationship with the people in
your film it you know it all comes down
to making sure that everyone feels
comfortable and that they trust you it
all comes down to trust so if they know
that they can trust you to make sure
that their you know image or that
whatever they're doing is going to be
portrayed you know in the way that the
documentary should portray it then
that's how you can really make a great
film and I think that you know that's a
risk that they're taking you know by
being part of any film or the any
characters taking by being part of a
documentary and that's the only way to
really do it they have to trust the
documentary filmmakers because if a
character in a film has a lot of
oversight or has like you know the right
to like you know screen everything
before it gets out there it really
affects how ethical we can be as
filmmakers and as storytellers
definitely yeah and I think every
situation is different to and every
relationship is different with your
subjects just like they are within your
relationship in your life and and I and
I think that view you are faced as a
filmmaker with some difficult choices in
that regard I've been when I go out to
Cambodia so the first time Stephanie I
went together but the last two times out
that we filmed I never it was just me
because Stephanie's been working on her
on a Netflix series but when we or when
I when I'm out there I have shown you
know shared with them like the trailer
we did we cut like a sizzle trailer I
showed that
to them because you know it's
interesting it's you know the risk is
they might not like what they see and
then shut down and you know close off
access but but the flip side of that is
they might really like what you see and
then open access and or at least trust
you more and but I kind of made that
choice to share what we had at the time
just because I thought that I you know I
wanted to be transparent and and keep
dem excited because it you know
filmmaking is a long special
particularly documentary filmmaking is a
long process and what you know I've been
out there a few times we film in for a
year and if they don't feel like
progress is being made or or their they
start to wonder what you're doing you
know there's that can also kind of a
road your relationship so it's always
constantly a bit of a balance and I
don't like to hide things but I also
don't necessarily like Stephanie said I
don't necessarily think it's also
helpful to show people early versions of
things because it's a half-formed idea
not a 4-leaf or mod or whatever and so
it doesn't even really represent
necessarily what you think is going to
be and I learned that on tiny actually
when we screened some work-in-progress
screenings that film festivals we did
twice and I regret doing that only
because you know you know people see the
first thing and then in their mind it's
that's what the film is always and you
never really get a second chance for a
first impression so yeah I guess that's
just to say it's all it's complicated
anything it's case by case
you